happy 2019 another day another gear how
often can you say that except once a
year I'm the first video of 2019 is
going to be my anticipated movies of
2019 this is the same way I want to say
top 10 that just 10 I address that
because one of the complaints in the
comment sections of my top 10
anticipated movies of your ex is that
they're all big movies like they're all
big movies all commercial movies so much
Marvel yeah what the [ __ ] else would be
on here what whatever artsy fartsy ass
movie is coming out next November it
might very well be good but I don't know
what it is yet what's talking about that
yet it doesn't have the publicity this
time last year I didn't even know about
upgrades so yeah there's gonna be a lot
of big movies on here don't be shocked I
just have my rolls what I like it's what
I am and please keep in mind there are
more than 10 movies I'm looking forward
to these are just there's a 10 that I
picked for a top 10 so when you wanna
comment below what about this movie just
say in your mind that's that's 11 I keep
in mind this isn't in order it's not
like 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 so I'm not
gonna do the countdown I'm just gonna
list these are more or less in order of
release so here we go first up we got
glass it feels weird putting glass on
this list because I see glass in a
couple weeks it comes out in a couple
weeks this is a sequel to unbreakable
and a split tie-in point is it's part
three of em night Shyamalan's comic book
hero trilogy or villain depending but I
love Elijah price I love unbreakable I
need to see the next chapter I just hope
it doesn't get lost I hope it doesn't
become so big that he cracks under the
pressure as what I've noticed about
Shyamalan if you look back at his work
every time there's no pressure on him
that's when he does his best work and
when there's pressure on him that's what
he does is not so best work and if you
like this pressure on glass so we'll see
next up we have Captain Marvel Captain
Marvel looks awesome the trailers have
been great I like the hero they even
changed the name of Captain Marvel -
Shazam crazy that copyrights oh yeah
that's what I'm looking forward to
Shazam what Captain Marvel did you think
I'm talking about the Captain Marvel
that had good trailers there's as simple
as this it's big meets Superman how
could I not how could I not and a head a
good trailer DC is on a pretty good roll
right now they're on a good flight path
I enjoyed Aquaman all we want to do is
enjoy Shazam I think Zachary Levi is
perfect to play a hero who's actually a
kid I just think it could be a really
cool adventure of fun pure time at the
movie and for those of you who are
confused right now about the Captain
Marvel Shazam thing that he used to be
named Captain Marvel to change it to
Shazam next up Avengers end game I know
it's a skin
crow now and that's on the list I mean
it's a game and game is just that's when
you know it's the end game Batman
endgame Highlander endgame one of those
two is actually really good like Thanos
did his thing
what's next they obviously have a plan
it has to work Steve Rogers even said so
in the trailer I don't want to see a lot
of marketing behind this like you've
sold me because it's Avengers endgame I
really doubt anyone's going to see
Avengers infinity war and be like I
don't need to see what happens next you
guys see what happens next like that's a
theme in this video actually you'll see
more movies where I'm like I just have
to see what happens next up Toy Story 4
why cuz I just have to see what happens
I thought 3 was the end I thought that
was just a wonderful toy story trilogy
and now we're getting four and that just
makes me go I hope it's good but it's
the track record that sells it the Toy
Story movies are so good with Toy Story
3 admittedly at the time I was like it
can't hold up it just can't it did
totally dead we got one breafast trailer
that shows you very little about the
movie other than putting pipe cleaners
and spoons together makes a toy and
makes it sentient the point is this the
fact that it's another chapter in Toy
Story is what makes me look forward to
toys Story 4 that's the thing that's
selling it for right now that's enough
for me alright next we have spider-man
far from home it's very simple here
spider-man fan fan of Tom Hollands
spider-man and fan of spider-man
homecoming also fan of Mysterio I've
been waiting for Quentin Beck to be on
screen forever so that's a good thing
this is saving grace of the fact that
there have been so many spider-man
movies out there they don't really want
to double up so it's like what else do
we got Mysterio good enough for me and
I'm like thank you it's gonna be for
everybody and everyone's gonna be like
how do we not get him sooner unless he
sucks in which case that's me being
wrong here but hey as of recording this
it's January 1st I'm losing my voice
what else I got I do wonder what what
are the stakes gonna be like why is
spider-man compelled to leave New York
to go on this adventure far from home
next up we have the live-action Lion
King adaptation yeah live-action The
Lion King is like top tier Disney
animation I just have to see what they
do with this point is I want to see a
live-action representation of the story
of The Lion King and I just don't have
the patience to sit through Hamlet it's
just real look before the internet melts
its own face off I know it's not
actually live-action like everything in
this Lion King movie is CGI so it's
animated but I don't care I'm gonna call
it live-action forever cuz that's the
intent you know they were like we're
gonna make a live-action Lion King
oh [ __ ] it's really hard to get lions
and animals to do that guess we'll have
to make it all CGI
I don't consider spider-man and Captain
America Civil War animated spider-man I
consider him live-action spider-man it's
meant to look live-action it's meant to
be taken in this live-action I'm gonna
call it live-action next up Quentin
Tarantino's ninth film Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood I know very little about
this movie I haven't seen a trailer on
this movie all I know is this Quentin
Tarantino dealing with the Manson
murders and margot robbie plays Sharon
Tay which is interesting because it is
Tarantino there's that part of my brain
look is it gonna follow the story I mean
Hitler died in inglorious basterds he do
can change history the families that the
victims are still alive it's still a big
feds I don't know is it gonna be a
comedy I don't know Barry Tarantino as
only Tarantino can do however psychotics
and serial killers that fascinate me
Tarantino I'm a fan of when the two come
together I just have to put on my 10
anticipator this movie had my curiosity
and it has my attention next on the list
we have it chapter 2 because it was
great I guess we should call it it
chapter 1 buddies of the Stephen King
horror stories that have been adapted to
movies it is the best what they were
going for they did it perfectly it's
like The Goonies with a fucked-up clown
that kills people it's not really clown
it's a boggart of some kind and after it
crushed you know that we're gonna get
some good actors to be like I'll play
the adult versions of them sure so they
have a solid cast coming I am in alright
I am in for it at the end of all of it
I'd like to see a super cut like someone
cut together it chapter one and it
chapter 2 and have it intertwine like
the book did and of course come on my
favorite character of all time I have to
see what hulking Phoenix does with the
Joker Joker Saul it's called right Joker
I was rewatching The Dark Knight
recently and I'm like that's what makes
Heath Ledger's Joker so great I mean
he's insane sure but he's in control of
the room when he's there that's what the
Joker needs to be if this is like
falling down with murders and a clown
maybe he'll be in the larval stage of
the Joker a different mental phase
entirely I still say they shouldn't have
ever said this was a joker movie did you
just had this movie about this guy going
crazy and in the end by the way it's
Joker and there was nothing else
wouldn't that be some [ __ ] if they
establish this is actually the Joker and
the Jared Leto Joker's actually Jason
Todd maybe they could allude to it
without making it final without giving
validity to things people probably don't
want validated whatever point is great
actor like walking Phoenix in the shoes
if a great character like the Joker
gotta see it and last on my list okay
Star Wars Episode nine it's all my
anticipated how could it not be let me
paint the picture for you JJ Abrams
comes in it's like I'm gonna resurrect
Star Wars fans generally we're like
sweet we're on board then Rian Johnson
comes in as like that cool story bro
burns it to the ground and now Abrams is
coming in like I all right I guess I got
to finish off this trilogy JJ Abrams
teed up the story lines to go places
Rian Johnson just kicked them all down
like Legos like I don't care maybe it's
more curiosity than anticipation in
which case maybe I should pull this off
and give another movie all right uh like
Jordan Peele anticipating that or had a
trainee dragon 3 that's a good one too
but I just I have to see where it goes
what's the good a - is he gonna wreck
Khan I doubt it is gonna act like the
last Jedi never happened no is he gonna
have the opening crawl be like after the
destruction of Starkiller base Luke
Skywalker gets a terrible vision of a
possible future to come so now he waits
at the Jedi Temple for Rey to meet him
for the first time
Rey is on her way there done it never
happened I don't know but I gotta see
how this plays out after this trilogy is
done I guess it's done it should be done
anyway give it a break Vegas back to a
time where every couple decades we got a
Star Wars movie every three years
between chapters but mark my words the
coolest thing that could have happen is
Rey turning bad and just taking up the
first order and being evil they won't
because they're not gonna have their
strong female lead turn back for some
reason that Cena's weakness I see it as
ambition but that's the coolest thing
they could have done at the end of the
last Jedi they didn't they won't do it
at the end of episode 3 or 9 I mean
we'll see where they go one thing I know
for sure the fanbase will be united for
this it's gonna be a peaceful time Yeah
right so those are my 10 movies my 10
movies I'm looking forward to in 2019
odds are most the movies on this list
are gonna suck when they come out and
the best movies of the year ones that
aren't even on my radar but for your
anticipated movies of 2019 what are you
looking forward to whatever they are
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]